everybody came to
the g7 in germany really hearing a lot
about ukraine fatigue the anxieties of
other countries around the world about
the continuing war the effect on food
prices on energy prices and what's
really struck me in the last couple of
days has been the amazing consistency of
uh
our resolve and the continuing unity of
the the g7 that was really honest there
aren't divisions absolutely sean through
in the in the conversation uh over the
last couple of days i think there's a
reason for that
the logic of the of the position is
still so clear there is no deal that uh
the president zalenski can can really do
so in those circumstances the g7 uh
supporters of ukraine around the world
have to continue to help the ukrainians
to to rebuild uh their economy to get
their grain out to export their grain
and of course we have to help them to
protect themselves and that's what we're
going to continue to do and the
situation in uh in the east uh uh in the
land bridge remains uh in the south of
the country south east of the country in
ukraine remains very difficult
but the ukrainians have shown that they
have incredible ability to push back and
change the uh the military position
you're on a eight-day foreign tour going
to three summits one after another
meanwhile your mps are gathering again
at westminster mps from the cabinet down
are speculating privately about your
future are you worried they're plotting
whilst you're away
no we we settled that a a couple of
weeks ago and what i'm yeah what i'm
focused on you know what we're doing
is
getting on with number one all the stuff
we're doing to help people with the cost
of living in the short term using the
fiscal firepower we have 1200 pounds for
8 million of uh the most vulnerable
households four hundred pounds uh to
help everybody three hundred pounds for
pensioners cutting council attacks all
the things that we're doing
in cash terms to help uh people through
the the current inflationary spike in
the cost of particularly energy
but also
getting on with the agenda for a strike
our plan for a stronger economy
reforming our supply side in energy
transport housing all the things that uh
that matter to people and then the the
general government agenda of leveling up
the country and delivering on our
program your plan to tear up part of the
brexit deal that you signed is going to
be voted on in the commons later how
soon will these changes to the northern
ireland protocol be in law how soon will
they be implemented
look the the interesting thing is uh
how little uh this conversation is being
had or up certainly here uh and
it's happening back home when people
want to know what you understand
what we're trying to do
is uh fix something that i think is very
important to our country which is the
balance of the belfast good friday
agreement and you've got one tradition
one community that feels that things
really aren't working in a way that
they
like or understand you've got barriers
unnecessary barriers to to trade from
great britain to northern ireland all we
are saying
is that you can get rid of those uh
whilst not in any way endangering the eu
single margin how soon how soon will
that happen i think we can do it fairly
rapidly but obviously what would be this
year what would be even better yes i
think we could do we could do it
very fast but
what you know parliament really
but what would be
um even better
and this i think uh
liz trust the foreign secretary has also
said this made this very clear be even
better as if we just get some of that
flexibility
we need in our conversations uh with
maharosh osefkovic and say well we
remain optimistic